with no further ado brothers and sisters
the Dean show me a la there's only one
word my man is his messenger Allah that
you have you
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice smell
alhamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be
unto you let's raise the roof here talk
beard now that wasn't a war cry that was
what we were saying in Arabic God is
greater greater than anything that you
can imagine bismillah al hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
to the Dean show I'm Eddie your host and
we're in washington d.c that's right
washington d.c were filming today in
front of a live studio audience
alhamdulillah all praise to the crater
of the hands on the earth I've mentioned
Washington DC so did President Obama get
a invitation is he here huh love gives
guidance to who he wills it'll
hamdulillah and Charlotte maybe you get
to see this so today my next guess we're
going to be talking about what do you
stand for what do you believe in what's
dictating your life are you on the
bridge are you on the edge are you
confused you don't know which way to go
do you have your ID is very important
that us as those who have submitted
ourselves to the One God not to the
creation of God but to the creator of
all that exists we know that this way of
life that was sent down by the creator
of the heavens and earth the way of life
that all the messages of God lived they
taught people they brought the same
message it was the same message
throughout time to submit your will to
the will of the one God and when you
have firm conviction in this this way of
life that's based on truth evidences
then you're proud to say i am one who
has submitted to the will of god i'm a
muslim but now you start changing in a
name from mohamed tomo you see your
brother or sister gives you a salam
and you cover it up you you're nervous
to give the piece back you don't know
your ID you don't have confidence in the
Muslim ID you go and you get dropped off
to school and then you end up turning
the corner the head job comes up you're
doing it why not because of Allah
because of your parents you fast what
not because you have firm conviction it
because what because you want to lose
weight because your parents making you
do it you're not firmly convinced and we
are going to be talking with my next
guess when we come back on a Dean show
the importance of knowing with full
conviction that this way of life is the
truth from the creator of the heavens
and earth so when you finish watching
this show you can be convinced knowing
that I'm proud to be a Muslim I have the
Muslim identity alhamdulillah this is
something that I stand firm I'm with my
next guest when we come back imam safi
count on the Dean show they're always be
someone that will be there to say
something negative but at the same time
there'll be someone there to say some
positive awesome just hold on to the
Rope of Allah everything in this
universe rely I need a lot of it the
Quran says don't kill women don't kill
children don't feel the old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told us
I am I am a female assa that the prophet
or solid never ever start a war against
any of us from i am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if allies by my side i am
not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
say salam alaikum peace be with you Imam
while it goes by him how are you I'm
didn't alhamdulillah we just said some
Arabic so not yet Muslims who are out
there they don't have to take an arabic
class can you define what you just said
alhamdulillah what does this mean under
that means praise and thanksgiving and
now some people you know they're there
under this false impression you said
Allah now you got to define because
again there's some confusion i think
what are they praising a moon god allah
is the proper name God as a matter of
fact this was a name that was used even
by previous generations even before
Islam as a matter of fact to this very
day Christians who speak Arabic they use
the name Allah or God mashallah
hamdulillah so we're praising the
creator of all that exists the same God
that Jesus worshiped and Noah worship
the God that created the sun in the moon
that one creator that's the phrase
creator that we're praising and thanking
and I thank him that he's given us this
opportunity me and the audience here
that we can benefit from your knowledge
you've been doing this a long time so
you heard me open the show moes going to
maha Mohammed's going to mow and Fatima
is going to fee see and she's making up
you know taking a job off turning around
the corner not confident in her Muslim
identity the brother also
he's also not confident doesn't have
firm conviction we want the people to be
confident to be Muslims what advice can
you give us a well living in the West it
is a big challenge to define yourself as
a Muslim but really the word itself when
you call yourself a Muslim what does
that mean and if you look at the
definition that means one who has
submitted to Allah one who has submitted
to God and that's where it really all
starts and if the most basic thing or a
Muslim is their belief system though
which is which we define in Islam or
which we call in Islam the rapida which
means your Creed in your faith and your
the whole belief system so if that is
strong that is strong in the heart of
the Muslim then a Muslim will not be shy
in the way that he or she behaves and
the way that he or she conducts himself
or herself no matter where they are
because they know first and foremost
that allah is watching and that they're
answerable to allah 17 times a day and
during the obligatory prayers a muslim
is saying surat al-fatihah which is the
opening chapter in the quran and in that
one of the verses says guide us to the
straight path guide us to the straight
path so it is a continuous thing on a
daily basis where not only are we asking
Allah who to guide us but in at the same
time we're affirming our worship to
Allah you alone do we worship and from
you do we seek help so we seek his help
to maintain that identity to submit to
him and to continue practicing the way
of Islam as much as we possibly can now
is it important do you feel that once a
person has firm conviction because we
know that Islam as submission to the one
create or not to a man not to a saint
not to a monkey not to elephant not to
the Sun not to
own but everything that God created is
not God but God is the one that is
responsible for maintaining us given in
our giving us the air that we breathe
taking care of the bird in the air the
fishing to see when we know that this
way of life that we're living is not
man-made it's not an organized religion
by man or men will be more confident in
it and does this take a little bit of
time to study in should every person be
dedicating so much time to get this firm
conviction by investing the same amount
of time you're investing in school to be
to get that PhD even to get that GE T
GED you have to study so should people
be studying Islam more to get this firm
conviction yeah of course this is one of
the basic things about his thumb the
very first word of revelation was to
read that was the very first word that
was revealed Islam traced it places a
high premium on learning and knowledge
Prophet Muhammad may peace and blessings
be upon him he said that the best of you
is the one who learns to put on and then
teaches it there is a Koran and then
teaches it in one saying of his hadith
he said that seeking knowledge is
obligatory and every Muslim man and
woman so it is important for us to learn
about Islam but the more importantly is
to practice what you know as you begin
to practice your identity will begin to
show it'll manifest itself and people
will know that you are a Muslim because
you carry yourself as a Muslim you
implement what you have learned and the
knowledge that you have you begin to
practice it and that's what's going to
make that's what through that people
will know immediately that this is a
Muslim like when you speak you speak
truth you don't lie when when you agreed
when you read people you say assalamu
alaikum which means may Allah's peace be
upon you and you is like making a prayer
for them almost in every expression that
you make you use the word of Allah like
if you say for example that I'll meet
you tomorrow or I'll meet you
after an hour you say I'll meet you
after an hour in sha allah if god
willing or allah wills or if you see
something nice you would say masha
allied this is the will of allah and so
on and almost in every expression that
the Muslim uses they use the name of
Allah emphasizing the fact that we
submit to Allah and Allah is always on
our minds that's what makes Muslim
different and that's what gives him or
her that ID that I am a Muslim I've
submitted to God now tell us do you also
feel shake that knowing the reasons is
it encouraged in Islam to ask questions
the parent should they be instilling in
their children as they're growing up why
they're wearing hijab not just say ok
you have to wear this because my parents
were my grandparents weren't which is
this is just part of our culture so when
they're asked at school why do you wear
this all because my parents make me or
they know that this is the the fashion
that Allah revealed from the seven
heavens he brought it down in a modest
way that a woman dresses to protect
herself that she's identifying the
believing women and then knowing the
wisdoms behind it and the same reasons
why do I pray five times a day are they
encouraged asked so then they're
confident to give these answers knowing
that there's substance there's meaning
behind this is not just a bunch of
rituals and rules and now I'm just doing
it because my parents did it well when
we come to any practice in Islam often
even those people who don't practice
they criticize that well this may be too
tough for me to do or this looks strange
it looks weird and unfortunately a lot
of Muslims who was faith is weak they
are affected by that as well actually
the bottom line is Islam is all about
being grateful to Allah and that's why
when for example at the beginning of the
program when you asked me how are you
doing I said alhamdulillah meaning that
I praise Allah I thank Allah I'm
grateful to Allah for being here today
for giving me another minute to live to
be able to glorify Allah so the bottom
line really is
how grateful we are to Allah so if we
want our children to practice Islam are
our sisters to wear the hijab I think
the first thing is for everyone to
realize children as well as adults that
Allah has done so much for us that Allah
has given us so much that allows
blessings rain down upon us day and
night moment to moment and if Allah has
given us so much shouldn't we be
grateful to him and it's part of our
gratitude let us do things that are
pleasing to Allah especially those
things that Allah has asked us to do so
among those things is wearing the hijab
that Allah has asked us to do this so
certainly if I understand that allah
subhanahu wata anna loves me to such a
degree that he is so forgiving that
almost anything I can I do so many
things that are wrong but Allah forgives
me I'm up hardened me Allah gives me
another chance unless so merciful if I
understand those things I begin to
understand a las love for me and Allah
giving me chances not only in this life
but also in the hereafter almost
everything that I do if I for example if
I do a good deed it doesn't count once
it counts ten times or maybe it may even
count seven hundred times more or even
more than that depending on my level of
sincerity so with a god of this nature I
would love to do anything that he asked
me to do and hence if that realization
is there then certainly I think our
sisters they would wear the hijab
willingly and not they wouldn't ever
feel that they're being forced to wear
it Marshall lon chay we're gonna take a
break and we'll be right back with more
here on the Dean show ease
about 60 years ago in former Yugoslavia
today's Bosnia at the Second World War
and imagine today you have one child
feel so much it's important that we
realize that Islam is a gift so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left is truthfully mean he is
the Prince but the truth has been mixed
up with paganism and with nature worship
and so Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
back here on the D show with shake safa
thank you again for being with us now is
it enough that a person just goes in
utters let's say some words in arabic
allah allah mohammad rasool allah and
now that person doesn't pray doesn't
fast brahma down comes around and you
know they're at the masjid and then the
rest of the year they're just like you
know a las mas merciful most kind he'll
understand I gotta work I got to make
money I don't really have time my boss
if he sees me taking the would do or put
my face on the ground I might get fired
I might not get hired if I wear the
hijab are you firm in your Muslim
identity when you're thinking like this
and it's a way to fall back on a las
mercy just saying he's you know a
rahmani raheem and just continuing life
like this ramadan ramadan but forgetting
about you know your twenty-four-seven
obligations to allah sheikh of course
for us as Muslims Islam is it completely
of life complete complete way of life it
means that in every step of the and
every step that we take every move that
we make everything that we say it is
designed it is supposed to please allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and that's why in
everything that we do the first thing
we're supposed to do is to have the
intention to do it sincerely for Allah I
think as long as that's the case then
not only won't we be Ramadan Muslims
will be year-round Muslims and the idea
is to when you practice Islam all the
time that's when your faith within
yourself is going to get stronger and
stronger and stronger but if you
practice it you know seasonally then
obviously it's going to be it's going to
be weak I would remind you and I remind
all of us that barring a Muslim identity
is such a critical issue such a crucial
issue that you find that heavy efforts
are being made to divest the most
of his or her identity for him or her to
go away from who or he from who he or
she is though it is critical for us not
only to educate ourselves but to provide
venues where we can begin to practice
and so people will become more and more
confident that yes what they're doing is
the right thing bearing in mind
especially that more and more people are
beginning to see the wisdom of Islam and
people are beginning to see that yes
it's not make sense but this is in
itself inshallah will begin to give
confidence to the Muslims that you look
maybe I am on to something I'm doing the
right thing rashel alhamdulillah now I
can't just go ahead and have all the fun
and ask all the questions so when I'm by
myself for when we're with the team in
the studio I get to have all the fun but
I want to get everyone else involved so
if anyone has some questions for the
shape go ahead now is your time to ask
raise your hand and we can come over and
ask you and let you ask some questions
don't be shy now sister right okay I
have a quick question I wanted to know
the difference between a messenger and a
prophet basically like with a Gabriel
will see like a messenger of course he's
a messenger but I want to know the exact
difference between wasn't messenger what
the Prophet a beer actually the question
is what is the difference between a
messenger and a prophet of course there
are many differences but just to briefly
put in a messenger is one who brings a
law and a prophet basically a messenger
is a specialized category of a prophet
oh the prophets they bring the message
but the messengers they they're more
specialized and they bring the law I
want somebody to ask a question who
knows a friend know somebody that is
struggling with their Muslim identity
and you want them to ensure I'll be able
to see this or that person is here
whatever the case oh oh I gotta run back
there ask okay we need some people in
the front who's going to ask after this
one so i don't have to exercise here
all rights just salon when I come work
Matilda he you a burka to Monaco salam
blame my mom she's a non-muslim and I
just want to know uh an advice how I can
I uh I know it's LOM the best way to
give someone hidayat her a message for
Islam is to show by example but she's in
another country can you please give me
more detail advice as how I cannot bring
her into Islam inshallah I think bearing
in mind that your mom is in another
country I think the best thing that you
could do is force through your conduct
through your character that you are in
touch with her regularly whether through
through email or through the phone and
whatever you can do to try to visit her
or try to bring her near you and then
try to be righteous towards her as much
as you possibly can to try to serve her
try to do things for her these are some
things that would really impress her and
of course as you begin to attend to her
needs and things of this nature as you
begin to have more and more
conversations with her whether email or
on the phone you can begin to talk to
her about Islam and how beautiful Islam
is and how it's made an impact in your
life and how it can make an impact in
her life masha'Allah do we have any not
yet Muslims here because everyone has
the potential to submit to the one guy's
very simple ah long alaikum peace be
with you how are you what's your name
Sam thank you for being here at the
conference are you having a good time
very very good time alright alright go
ahead ask the question my question is
mainly can you clarify jihad it's like
it's like a something use a lot and it's
kind of like contribution to a confusing
issue who are not in the Muslim faith
it's like Gibson but for
case and detailing exactly what that is
good question good question shake can
you clarify he wants to know jihad holy
war you hear it on the news and people
getting scared like the boogeyman is
coming please ask our guests answer our
ghost questions about jihad ok jihad
actually it comes from the Arabic word
jihad ah which means to exert yourself
to exert your energy to do something and
to be serious about doing something so
when people hear the word jihad which is
a noun of the verb jihad ah it means to
basically exert yourself to do something
and it could be for example when one
goes on a diet and one is trying to
avoid various foods this could be
considered a jihad because you're
exerting an effort to stay away from
certain things and it's a struggle
within yourself and so on sometimes when
you for example when you are studying at
a university and it takes a lot of
effort for you to study and to stay up
at night and two and two to keep on
studying and to make sure that you do
well on your exams and you let go of
things and you sacrifice things you
don't go to the regular meetings or
parties that you're used to going your
schedule is totally different it totally
changes this is a form of jihad jihad
when it comes to Islam certainly does
not mean holy war there are many aspects
of jihad many different aspects of jihad
basically the issue is to struggle one
of the issues that the media
concentrates on is that it just means
more or is one of the aspects of jihad
but again it's an absolute last resort
type thing and it is to defend oneself
and if necessary to go on the offense
but it is some
is there like 13 14 different levels of
this struggle that comes and the first
of course is to to have the right belief
to struggle to have the right belief to
to learn to practice to be patient who
to go get over one's desires and things
of this nature so all these things are
involved in what we called you have and
again this is a very brief answer Thank
You mashallah we're going to take a
break Sam that was a excellent question
and I want every this is our VIP guests
over here I want everybody to make an
effort to from the brothers to introduce
yourself to our special guest Sam and
we're going to take a break and be right
back with more here on the Dean show
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred-thousand-dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here on earth which
it's not anyone's job to go into
someone's hard to change their heart
your job is to topi what the truth is
and the ally of it is while we're
sitting here while i'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease the
kill was free
back here on the Dean show shake we're
running out of time so if you can now
give some closing comments and
suggestions for those people out there
who agree with what's in their very
nature that I didn't create myself I
didn't just come from nothing did there
is a God there is a create tour in
Arabic we call him Allah the same God
that Jesus worship the same God that
Abraham knowing all the messages of god
jesus said worship the father who art in
heaven and that's what we're doing just
just worshiping God giving God all the
rights making God the center of
attention in our lives people are
struggling they're a little bit nervous
they're you know they're scared what he
or she or my boss so this person's going
to say they're struggling but they have
it in it in themselves but they just
need a little bit motivation little bit
encouragement please talk to him [ __ ] I
think when when it comes to our
relationship with God again it goes back
to the issue of how grateful we are to a
lot how grateful we are to God and the
more that realization sets in the more
you will begin to practice and the more
you will begin to see the wisdom of
Islam because every virtual e everything
that you study about Islam it makes
sense that yes this is definitely the
right thing to do now it is so important
for us as Muslims to stand for what is
right to stand up for the truth and as
Muslims in this world when people adopt
a system that is that does not come from
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala they
inevitably make mistakes and they hurt
other people Islamic Wayne is a solution
all the problems that humanity in
general faces Islam being a complete way
of life has a solution for everything
for us is Muslim weather is
educationally weather spiritually
weather is politically whether it is
economically Islam has it's a body of
knowledge that deal
with each one of these areas now as we
close one of the most important things
for us as Muslims is to understand that
the Muslim identity is under attack and
to know that there's a lot of pressure
for Muslims not to be who they are
supposed to be and hence it is even more
critical it is even more crucial for the
Muslims to practice more and more of
what Allah and His Prophet have asked us
to practice alpha Muhammad may peace and
blessings be upon him he one time he
said he was asked who are the friends of
allah and he responded by saying that
the Friends of Allah are those people
that when they are seen Allah is
remembered Allah is remembered so I
would encourage all of us to begin to
learn more and more about Islam and
begin to practice more and more about
Islam and begin to live in a community
setting so you're encouraged and you're
more and more motivated to practice
Islam Jake thank you very much we began
with peace we end with peace and may god
almighty the Creator Allah rewards you
for being with us thank you honey lake
lucerne al rato cut and thank you
everybody here for being with us stick
around we're going to do another show in
sha allah in a few and for those who are
out there who want to learn more about
islam call the number on the screen 1
800 662 is slum pick up the verbatim
word of god the qu'ran we'll see you
next time peace be unto you
I am NOT alone I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid bismillah halal makin peace be
with you we greet you with the greetings
of all the messengers of God that
greeting of peace and after that we
could say what's up how you doing but we
started with peace and we're here in
front of a live studio audience in
Washington DC is everybody having a good
hollow good time let's do it one more
time to be it you raise the roof haha
hamdulillah I'm excited I'm excited to
be here and it's something beautiful
because the more you learn about this
Dean this way of life that is ordained
from the creator of the heavens and
earth the more your Iman it starts to
increase and that's a blessing one of
the great blessing that Allah the
Creator has given me the ability to be
here and then we're being able to be
here together so it's double the reward
I'm getting the benefit press record and
then share it with the world hamdulillah
so we can all benefit together and
today's topic it's a nice topic today's
topic wherever you're watching around
the world around the globe is that peer
pressure you got your peers you got your
group of friends and now they're putting
pressure on you you're trying to do good
but then they're calling you too bad
you're trying to stay on the correct way
the way that is ordained from none other
but the creator of the heavens and earth
and they're over here trying to
influence you you to go the wrong way so
we want to get some advice how not to
succumb to that negative ad peer
pressure when we come back here live
from Washington DC on the Dean show with
my next guest Shaquille nasha kilo
shake shake he'll be right back Allah
there's only one word Muhammad is His
Messenger Allah Allah there's only one
God and Jesus was his messenger Allah no
I did that maybe it maybe it's just to
break the ice Salaam alaikum share while
it comes to LA what happens a lot peace
be with you how are you alhamdulillah
praise to the creator of the heavens and
earth was given us this ability to be
here so we're going to be because time
is short we have so much to talk about
and this way of life is about advice
advising the good advising people to
stay away from bad and that definition
is defined obviously not by our desires
but is defined by what God Almighty the
crater is defined as good and that's the
ultimate good and we want to do good
because we want the reward the reward of
paradise we want to get to paradise
because this life is short you can die
at any time so peer pressure sometimes
gets people away from doing good for
instance you know give you an example
young man young boy young women they're
at a little social event and you know
what they get a little bit trick trap
and they go and to a place and they
thought is going to be just you know
having some lunch some dinner next thing
you know that the bong is coming up
these guys are doing it the guy sticks
around for a little bit you know how the
guys get around the guy go go go go go
and next thing you know he's chugging
the bong and now I did like come on imma
just try it man beat what just try it
come on he's like and then he starts
blushing he's like nervous he wants to
escape but he's got about ten football
players around him come on you I why
you're acting like a girl man he knows
he shouldn't be drinking and he sir
comes how do we not sir come to that
peer pressure shake give us some advice
well I think the first thing everyone
should understand that peer pressure is
not something new it's existed in
history and it exists today and it will
exist Alyssa panatela mentioned peer
pressure talk about peer pressure in the
Quran
at inland latina a gem you can Amina
latina a minus y el kun way tomorrow be
him at allama zone that lost consulate
the criminals they used to laugh at the
believers but they'll call you your
girly there laughs at you there scoff at
you newhall Islam was building the ship
they were laughing at him it's not
raining there's no flood why are you
building a ship you know we have our
pants above the ankle they say the same
thing there's no flood was your pants
above the ankle alright so they're gonna
they're gonna scarf they're gonna laugh
they're gonna make fun what the key
solutions the strength comes in the same
sort of lies all ties a challenge of
peer pressure with the AXA a yeoman
latina a minus Alice sponsor says down
bad day here after the believers will
laugh whoever gets the last laugh laughs
the best but what should it be afraid of
peer pressure it exists it's part of
life or one should know how to deal with
it the way to deal with it is to at that
moment when you're being pressured link
yourself with the after ah look yourself
in a completely different world the
asada that's how you get yourself out of
that current situation should you always
you just mention aji de now this is the
hereafter should you always be thinking
is a good to fan aside because you know
people end up watching TV and they fenna
Phi kind of fantasize about the wrong
things you know we had what's-his-name
congressman or senator Weiner that's his
name Weiner right and he was fantasizing
got him in a lot of trouble so people
are fantasized should we as those who
believe in the one God and last and
final messenger including all the
messengers of God including Jesus Moses
Noah should we fantasize about the
reward of paradise getting to see the
face of our Lord getting to be in
eternal bliss and happiness and this
will this encouraged us to be on the
correct way and not to succumb to
temporary joys temporary amusement
temporary fun we have to on what I'll
deal i know one day came to the house of
the prophet muhammad saw said I mean saw
it was basically bear a cot and the
water skin rafas awesome had marks on
his body or sleeping on that rough cut
Oh model Delano started to weep said o
Messenger of Allah the kings of Rome and
Persia have all this luxury why don't
you make door either Allah give us
something I prophesize I'm hearing that
Radha from the cot Eastern model delano
said official can untie even some odd
I'm at olive bar and along with duniya
what an ass Cara he stood up and he
addressed the situated situation he said
are you in doubt or hey broseph on the
opposite of certainty are you in Dow
organelle kebab no sonable kebab aren't
you pleased at a get is duniya we get
the action here the prophet saw some is
teaching him how to fantasize about the
alcon you see a situation you not
pleased with you see a situation you
wish could be better but you have
nothing at that moment to make it better
fantasize about the alcohol it's amazing
amazing also I mean there is the flip
side to that I mean we're yearning for
that eternal bliss in paradise by doing
good Islam calls to everything good
noble behavior character being good to
your neighbor non-muslim or Muslim and
worshiping God on his terms not making
up you know things according to your
desires so you get the reward on that
day of judgment but also are there
consequences that a person who disobeys
the crater lives life according to the
desires that they should think about to
the Hellfire very high place we don't
want to be there Jay think about this
too definitely and I mean some of some
of the times of youth they may say well
we're young I'm going to fool around a
little bit you know here in America or
most cities people get serious when
they're 35 or 40 now right 30 is the new
18 I don't know what is right so they
get serious at a very late age but in
Islam we get serious and mature at an
earlier age the province of lice autumn
when it came time to send an ambassador
to medina he didn't send Abubakr who was
his right-hand man who was the most
knowledgeable companion he said moose
I've been a mere a young man carry the
message of Islam so the youth may at
times well I can fool around a little
bit now now get serious later but what
they have to remember is how lost the
parrot I talked about to you he said
in now 52 an admin of European was at
the helm or that I talked about the
people of the cave they weren't they
weren't elderly people and I said that
surely their 50th they were young men
who believed in lies i was young it went
against the peer pressure to worship
idols to make sure so much to the point
they did not compromising the resort and
it went to a cave prophet muhammad's
doesn't talk about seven people who be
under the shade of a lone a day where
there's no shade talked about the
hotness being hot the Sun will be
brought a mile close we will sweat as
we've never sweated before you think
this summer is hot sweat people sweat
according to their sins some people will
sweat just below their feet some people
will have sweat up to the shoulder some
people be drowned in this wet and one of
the categories of people who will be
saved from that heat and that's what is
a young man worship of London's youth we
can't waste is precious time there's
precious moments in our life which is
the you gotta pass the test the test is
almost over again at any time def is a
reality we can die today tomorrow and we
need to take it seriously now let's give
one more example before we go to break
you know fatima aisha and she's around
some people possibly you know she thinks
to her friends and she's changing her
life she's saying that i need to get
serious so she's in between she's in
between the good group of fans the bad
group of friends what advice do you have
for you know she's caught in a situation
now or to avoid a situation where the
friends invite her over say come on girl
let's go hang out at this party you know
you can come to my house and my mom will
cover for us don't worry about it we can
go have a good time we won't stay up too
late everybody's going to be there now
she everybody who's going to be there so
what should she do in this situation a
couple of things first the first part is
to be proactive number one the preface
awesome said or july adenosine ed
rendell I had to come on you're hoggin a
man is upon the religion of his close
friend so look to whom you take as your
close friends your buddies to be
proactive you got to choose the right
friends you can't say well i'm going to
you know stay away from the haram even
though they do her arms are doing it
themselves that's impossible
prophesizing forbade us to drink liquor
even for beta to sit in an arena or a
place where someone else is drinking all
idea is that it's been a
and send it's going to transfer to you
that's the first thing to be proactive
to select the right friends number two
if we haven't done that and recorded a
situation what I like to tell the youth
is stopped for a moment all you can
pause our Smart TVs these day right
files can be pause pause your moment
right there pause take it to the end
game what's the end game if you take
products what's the end game if you
drink what's the end game if you commit
adultery don't take it step by step
because shake on is taking you take it
taking you step by step and doesn't want
you to see the end game skip those
chapters see the end game what is the
end game you don't have to live through
to the end game so many people already
failed a wise person is the one who
benefits and learns from other people's
failures not so wise person is somebody
who despite people have failed I went
through the path goes of that path
himself and goes to rehab and realize it
was a good idea to get pregnant then
realize it wasn't a good idea to have a
child without being married to her then
realizes that drugs has really screwed
my life but to look at the end game
before even entering to the game if the
end game is good pursue it the end game
is bad anyway amazing advice we're going
to take a break and be right back with
more with shakes Akhil here on the Dean
show
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred-thousand-dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here are not any one
job to go into someone's heart to change
their heart your job is for Toki what
the truth is and the ally of it is while
we're sitting here while i'm sitting
here constantly paying for the disease
the kill was free back here on the Dean
show given some real advice for real
situations peer pressure and you
mentioned good companionship good
friends you're around bad company bad
friends you're going to end up doing
some bad things can we give a real live
example for instance I mean if it's
worth something to you you're going to
sacrifice if you want to get that degree
and you have friends calling you now to
cut class you know to not study be away
from the study circles you'll see like
you said the end result you're going to
see I'm going to get my PhD my degree
I'm going to make good money have a big
house big car you're going to not hang
around with certain people who are
distracting you diverting you if we want
to get to paradise we want to earn the
pleasure of the creator of the heavens
and earth it's the same thing here isn't
it good companionship be away from
people who are drinking doing drugs not
like thinking like oh word like so pious
and right calling them to this that's
better than that because obviously the
creative prohibitory these things
they're bad for us so is this a way an
example maybe you give some nails so
people can really this can hit home well
basically I think that's a very good
point a lot of people go with the flow
go with the wind I come to peer pressure
simply because of that panic thought
I'll be depart I'm gonna miss out I want
to lose out you know what when you're a
Muslim you're a believer it's a win-win
situation always always the prophets
doesn't generally described it that the
affair of the believers always good
alright if something good happens to him
he's happy I me bad happens to him
patient and his sins a removed so it's
always a win-win situation so in this
situation what you should
do and look at the thing that he's going
to leave but don't think it's a loss
because it's actually an investment and
a game because the process of why some
segments are kashagan in there or what
the holos a time in whoever leaves
anything for the sake of Allah Allah
will replace it there's no loss although
we'll replace it I would something equal
to it Allah will replace it with
something better than if you lose you
let go of that Haram relationship you're
gonna get a better one if you let go of
that oh well I can't get a hi I'm not
going to i want to feel this I from
drugs I was gonna give you something
that's more beneficial to be in this
life her camellia charla hamdullah great
advice now we're going to take some
questions from our live audience does
anybody have a question as relevant to
the topic here that they like to ask
ache o neil young brother here only no
shake shake O'Neill just say [ __ ] real
shake for real shake for real yo for
real Shaquille for real we we have do we
have we have our VIP guests brother
Sammy Sam does do we have any other not
yet Muslims here that would like because
as I said everyone has the potential to
submit to God the same God that Jesus
submitted to that Moses submitted to
that's the guy the God that created you
and everything in this universe that is
what a Muslim is one who submits two god
so is there any of knots and precedence
what let's give sam presence your sam is
there any other night yet Muslims Sam
you want to ask another question go
ahead brother you have e AI pas ass ask
away oh well today during one of the
lectures I want my friend Hans and Tommy
here um let me know that Christianity
and Islam kind of share the same
progress I did not know that at all so I
kind of want to know well how do you
guys feel about Jesus Christ like when
create application so when I say like
he's the son of God how would you
respond to that right shake take it away
what question thank you
let me just a nutshell tell you that as
Muslims we believe in all the prophets a
day of judgement when the Jews will be
questioned you believe in Jesus Christ
their answer will be no on the day of
judgment when the Christians would be
questioned do you believe the Prophet
Muhammad the loss of them their answer
will be al Qaeda issue here let's let's
repeat back let's read that again on the
day of judgment when the Christians will
be questioned you believe in the Prophet
Muhammad supplies that I'm the answer
will be no on the day of judgment when
the Muslims will be question do you
believe in Moses our answer will be do
you believe in Jesus do you believe in
Mohammed I like his latter was so much
mine so Islam is the full package why
would you settle for anything less Islam
is the only religion the world that does
that does not deny a single prophet or
messenger of god almighty having said
that what do you believe about Jesus
Christ we believe he was the Christ was
the Messiah he's a prophet of God he's a
Messenger of God he is not God because
he was born from a human being Mary
imagine imagine he's in the belly of
Mary being born the umbilical cord has
to be cut off that's God there that
can't be gone or imagine that being son
of the son of god if we say jesus christ
is the son of god then he has to be
divine because the son of a human is a
human the cub of a lion is an animal and
we see the Son of God someone's the Son
of God and the Sun has to be divine has
to be God and if you do that and you
have to God's not one if we say no the
Son of God is not God then what do you
mean by Son of God if you say he's a
human being then why do you call them a
son of God because everyone else is a
right so what is that title mean or in
Islam we say causes a lot of confusion
so what we say is Jesus Christ not
define human being is not to be
worshipped creation is not to be
worshipped but the creator of creation
is to be worshiped now I have a question
for you Sam
why aren't you Muslim I don't know let's
find out do you believe in one God or
two guys one guy about three gods it
sounds like a little more yeah this one
guy only one yes GK is Jesus God you
believe jesus god yes Jesus God yeah
here's a quick question for you who came
to the earth God the Father or Jesus
Christ these guys godson ok so you said
Jesus is God then when I asked you who
came to you to the earth God or Jesus
you said Jesus how many guards that I
don't make to you god that'd be too so
let's repeat the question how many gods
you believe in we're like I'm being put
in a tight spot here now don't be polite
this tell the guy next to you to move
over a little bit oh ok in other words
that's what we don't say he's God
because you have two gods and you can't
get around that right I see what's the
first commandment um oh wow yeah that's
I have no other guy before what that's
gonna dice I have no other guy before me
oh the God except creator right only one
so whenever I dear friend whenever the
equation is more than one there's
something wrong they say Jesus is God
equation is more than what one it's a
problem right Oh is Jesus God I still
believe Jesus God hey so how many guys
do you believe in then technically two
okay good no I appreciate you being
honest a lot of people will say one
right but good your math is good you
took calculus yes is it showing so
there's two so what I want to do today
is think about that technical problem
and there's no solution in the world
except this slam know why I say that no
I say that yeah this is what I want you
to leave with tonight
namely our religion on the face of this
earth that does two things leaves in
Jesus Christ and believes in one God
namely those women which religion
believes in Jesus Christ and only one
God no technical problems is low huh
it's the Islam think about that okay
think about that okay thank you again ma
thank you thank you we're down we're
going to take a break and we right back
with more here on the D show live in
Washington DC in the name of
the most gracious the most merciful I
secret beautiful
the Lord of mankind the king of mankind
the god of mankind from the evil of the
Whisperer who whispers evil in the
hearts of men who withdraws from his
whisper finding one's heart after one
remembers of love
who is was in the hot Sun and kind of
gin and Manning I secretive alone
I seek refuge with Allah
Oh have mercy on us